[Music]
then disrespectfulness Oh ball I'm back
submitted by che from Kingston Kingston
Mon Katherine Heigl Oh like a solo until
chef ah she smokes I never watch it
right yeah
gosh she's such a [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
Mike I don't know I just don't like her
like her face
oh there's not I just know she was a
chain smoker and I was like oh I don't
like change
oh diva has apologized after posing for
selfies in a cemetery what's the context
what if [ __ ] idiot dude are you the
context I did a skit in a cemetery
I don't want to feel like an [ __ ] you
did what was this kid about though about
Jessica dying
well the scene calls for it yeah but
then did you get permission from the
person I didn't put it on any I didn't
put any names and the headstones and
stuff like that I just walked around sad
in the growth and a not to grocery store
at the garbage yard garbage garbage
do you it there's so many offensive
routes is kind of crazy did so one of
those people that the chinks the gooks
the [ __ ] would I ever say on this
[ __ ] shadow that tops anything I
understand know you call cremation
roasts yeah you do that's pretty [ __ ]
up that's exactly my father was cremated
so I don't appreciate but he was roasted
oh I saw my grandma my grandpa get
roasted that's so sad you weren't you
there we saw Mike drop it you
insensitive bastard you know what's
[ __ ] crazy
no don't say anything you're gonna cry I
know a lot of people got roasted though
ya know but then people got a notice
people got non-sports crazy
can you just clean the [ __ ] green
[ __ ] out of your teeth already
in like four hours roasting sounds so
positive yeah
roasting is a bad thing even when joking
you get roasted because you lady doesn't
make sense because they don't turn the
cream but that's nice it's a nice no I
don't want my person to turn to cream I
want to get roasted
you know what's crazy so this is
probably a cry right now from laughs
their [ __ ]
in Taiwan there's a space problem right
it's a really small island and it's
super densely populated so you have no
other option regardless of your
religious preference but to cremate
because a lot of people in Taiwan are
Buddhist it's like a thing to see once
someone gets cremated to see if there's
like these little jewels that come out
of her like your body peral's bad girls
like it represents that they went to
like man or the enlightened or whatever
right and so when you think like
cremated you think like complete even
ash and dust not yeah so I'm like when
they get when they come out with like
these metal trays when you go to like
the but does it call the crematorium yes
yes not the roasted Torian you just see
it's nuts rotisserie yeah the entrance
the entrance you just see rows of
[ __ ] Hurst's like semi trucks right
ready to drop off their shipment and all
the other end is just rows of people
passing out metal trays and bones a
half-burnt skulls and stuff and I saw
like my grandpa's a skull and I'm like
this is [ __ ] like it just comes out
and then I it was mind-blowing to me but
immediately my mom went in looking for
[ __ ] pearls and [ __ ] and I'm just
like a [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and then and
just all this just looking for and now
I'm just and you see a lot of people
doing the same thing as examining them
and I'm just like you were in Taiwan
doing this yeah I saw it with my own
eyes dan that's crazy cuz you see like
some skulls are completely intact
sometimes it's half a skull yeah you see
a femur it's crazy yeah yeah yeah they
do that in Japan what they don't look
for the pearls and start digging in the
[ __ ] ashes
do the they do the chopstick thing yeah
that I did that yeah well that's why you
can't when you pass food in you know
like for Japanese you don't do chopstick
you chopstick yeah because that's how
they [ __ ] transfer the bones and [ __ ]
yeah when they're doing all that I keep
asking what but then you you just leave
out that part asking when they do what
you said when they do that what's that
mean oh when you get the cremated bones
and the ashes and stuff like that and
then there's a burial ceremony oh did
you guys just use your hands no not at
thinking about those chopsticks but I
think to see how wild my mom was I just
saw [ __ ] hands dignities when you
said that your mom I saw a dog digging
in a hole that's how I pictured so cute
when they literally pictured your mom
doing this and you're like what the [ __ ]
you do she looks up there's ashes all
over mortified I was like no it's also
emotional very emotional you kind of
your memory is not the clearest yeah so
it's just like yo just know a week of
emotions so I was just like and also
going through some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
like that I'm just like all supposed to
roast my cremate my mom when she passed
away no way she's going to but she
changed her mind on me she said she
wants me buried now she should because
then you can go and visit you can but
then if they want to be sprinkled like
your mom wants to be sprinkled oh [ __ ]
the toilets she was like I want my ashes
to be thrown into the ocean now so I'm
putting you the toilet did and
eventually you're gonna be like [ __ ]
oh you're gonna be on sale boy you gotta
[ __ ] toss it so [ __ ] dramatic did
anyway Katherine Heigl here so she
recently went to go visit her brother
and her grandparents and at a cemetery
because her brother died when he was 16
in a car accident twin brother I don't
know if it's her twin I don't know why I
thought about that I thought was this
one brother something but nevermind yeah
so her brother so she posted these
photos you're there oh yeah what's wrong
with that
they make it seem like yeah I thought it
was like a selfie with their [ __ ]
core like [ __ ] like like selfie like
this and then like it's like a [ __ ]
graveyard and I'm gonna do dad [ __ ]
well she's not done wait there's more so
then she ended up posting this she was
like oh it just doesn't seem like
chatted with the lady usual man that is
that is that uh this is someone else's
[Music]
yeah and then her husband here just
posing with that's a dope ass tombstone
is a dope [ __ ] it just says Kelly
damn that [ __ ] looks like a big-ass
[ __ ] Arrowhead yeah and then she
posted a video of her husband like
walking through the cemetery like with
an arm around a ghost and just like
chatting with the ghost and so a lot of
people were really offended I'm sorry
but I don't think this any of this stuff
is bad so then she ended up posting this
video I realized you guys are right and
that was not appropriate and was
disrespectful and I've taken it down
somebody commented it was kind of just
saying that they didn't think it was an
appropriate thing to do but that I was
probably trying to make a hard moment
light hearted and that's exactly what I
was doing it's it's kind of a heavy
thing to go and visit my loved ones
graves and I decided to try to find some
moments of levity and humor and didn't
realize how inappropriate I was being I
deeply apologize and I thank you guys
for understanding that
I don't think things through clearly
enough and I am grateful for your input
and for kind of giving me a heads up
when I'm maybe going too far and thank
you for forgiving me next time I will be
more thoughtful about other people's
feelings and not just my own [ __ ] I
don't hate her that much ma'am you know
what sucks though that's pretty nice Oh
like I can see how people are like oh
man those are other people's dead family
members how can you just leave God that
disrespected their tombstone whatever
but also if that's not your direct
family member
why are you getting so angry you know a
little bit it could have been but it
also kind of reminds me of like what's
happening now where there's people
outside of certain like ethnic races and
they're getting more mad than that
ethnic race is getting when it has
nothing to do with them it's like me
getting mad over like Mexican people
right oh my god how could you do this to
[ __ ] Mexicans and then you're like
calm the [ __ ] down I don't even give a
[ __ ] about that but that's like then you
could apply that to a lot of other
people's logic like when Lo in Paul went
to Japan he was disrespecting Mecca it's
not my country why the [ __ ] am i mad
yeah I think because Asians have the
[Laughter]
band because it Japan because I've been
there they're just such a peace-loving
country everyone everything so organized
I'm not but they talk so much [ __ ]
behind your back they do but they do it
in these like very pleasant whispers and
when you see a [ __ ] barbarian go
there and just [ __ ] wreak havoc
beautiful dude every grandpa grandma I
see in there I'm like reminds me of my
grandpa grandma oh how are you gonna
[ __ ] up [ __ ] my grandpa over like that
yeah he's just trying to sell some fish
um that sounded very genuine and I
dislike her a lot less now I'm probably
not I probably made that statement like
it doesn't seem that bad to me is
because I immediately knew what she was
doing
from the photos like I knew it's like
she was just trying to make light of the
situation cuz it's it's hard dealing
with pain it's hard a lot of people cope
with humor right but when
she's a public figure and she has to
hold herself up to a certain standard
she can't be a regular goofy woman
anymore I think it makes it a little bit
weirder just because she was documenting
it you don't mean they don't have to
post it and that I mean going that
additional step so I think like yes and
people cope with you know hard times by
you know using laughter but then to take
a picture of it I would have done stupid
[ __ ] like I take a picture of it again
forever
I recorded a vlog at him I'm not a vlog
I did a skit in a graveyard it's pretty
bad bro I don't care I think I think I
think I have more of a go ahead I don't
care that she took the photos it's more
that she posted it yeah like you could
still have that like within your friends
like that's that moment for you to send
it to your fail yeah yeah like you and
your buddy is putting it into a public
forum and a public space is a different
thing because I imagine if I go to my
grandparents graveyard and somebody's
dancing around her grave guard you know
doing that [ __ ] I probably take a knife
or stick it to their [ __ ] chest I
made sure that the grave yard that I
went to no one visited them anymore
how because those [ __ ] headstones
were so old it's like from like 1820
Mike come on man there's no family
members doing you anymore you lucky to
have me around looking in a mirror
yeah man the ghost just comes up thank
God somebody than me yeah it's like it's
like those old people at the senior
citizen home that bet think that you're
the [ __ ] grandson that came I'll
pretend I do that [ __ ] when I go visit
my grandma
[Music]
[Music]